hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast transcript the transcriptome
assembly computational challenges
next-generation sequence data I am Bob
Woodard and I'll be your moderator for
today's event we have a few
announcements before we begin this
presentation is designed as an
interactive event and we encourage you
to submit questions during during the
broadcast you can submit your questions
by clicking on the green Q&A button in
the lower left corner of the
presentation window I'll try to answer
as many questions as we can you can
enlarge the slide window by clicking on
the screen icon the lower right of the
slide window if you have any technical
problems with the audio or visual part
of this presentation please click on a
support button at the type top right of
your presentation window or submit your
problem to the Green Q&A button on the
lower left I would like to now like to
introduce these figures dr. Stephen
Salzburg dr. Salzburg is the Bloomberg
distinguished professor of biomedical
engineering computer science and
biostatistics and the director of the
Center for computational biology at
Johns Hopkins University after
completing his PhD at Harvard in 1979
dr. Salzburg joined Hopkins as an
assistant professor of computer science
from nineteen seven nineteen ninety
seven to 2005 he was senior director of
bioinformatics
at the Institute for genomic research in
Rockville Maryland from 2005 to 2011 dr.
Salzburg was the director for the center
of bioinformatics and computational
biology and the Horvitz professor of
computer science at University of
Maryland College Park in recent years
dr. Salzburg and his students have
introduced several pioneering highly
efficient systems for analysis of
next-generation sequencing data
including the bowtie top hat and
coupling systems which are now used by
thousands of labs around the world all
the group software is free and open
source and their systems have been
downloaded thousands of times in
addition to a software system dr.
Salzburg has contributed analyses to
many genome sequencing projects
including the human genome multiple
plant and animal genomes and many
bacteria
he was co-founder of the influenza
influenza genome sequencing project the
first large-scale genomic study of the
human influenza virus doctor Salzburg
has authored or co-authored over 250
scientific publications he is a fellow
of the American Association for the
Advancement of science and of the
International Society for computer
biology communicational biology he was a
2013 winner of the Benjamin Franklin
award for open access in the life
sciences and the 2013 winner of the
Robert G bales prize and critical
thinking for his Forbes Science column
in 2001 and again in 2014
dr. Salzburg was listed as a highly
cited researcher by Thomas Thomson
Reuters a compilation of the 1% most
cited researchers in the world
please welcome Ian please join me in
welcoming dr. Salzburg I'll now turn the
presentation over to him ok thanks very
much Bob so today I'm going to talk
about transcriptome assembly and
compositional challenges that this
entails with next-generation sequence
data first let me just quickly point out
that my lab does work in a number of
different areas one of them is
transcriptome analysis which is today's
topic and that involves how you take the
sequences that come up on
next-generation sequencer and alignment
of genome and turn them into information
on which genes are present all talk I'll
talk much more about that over the
course the next 45 minutes but I also
work on to some of different areas that
it's going to mention one is genome
assembly or you know assembly which is
the problem of taking sequences and
putting them short sequences and putting
them back together to reconstruct
chromosomes for nutria genomes that
haven't been settled before and another
is is human microbiome which is studying
the microbial life that lives on our
bodies inside of our bodies and some of
the techniques in each of these areas
are related to what I'll talk about
today but I'm not
I'm talking about that work so let me
move on to talk about next generation
sequence data and the transcriptome
assembly promise so first let's go back
in time a little bit to 2001 human
genome was published as I'm sure you all
know there was an exciting race to get
that done they concluded with these two
publications in February of 2001 on
paper published in science by a private
group led by Solera genomics a group
that I collaborate went to the time and
another much larger consortium of
publicly funded groups that published
their paper on the human genome in the
journal Nature and that was the
culmination of work that started in 1989
when the human genome project was
launched and it was a really impressive
activity in the amount of sequencing
amount of an s12 that was was enormous
and and yet looking back on it today
not that long not much later we we could
actually say that the amount of data
that went into it is not big at all
compared to what the kind of bonds are
dealing with today so some time to
change due to the introduction of the
next-generation sequence data so let me
just give an example to illustrate how
they've changed since those days a few
years ago these are some numbers from an
exome sequencing project that we that we
did here at Hopkins where we're we're
sequencing thousands of exomes in an
effort to understand human disease this
is not a project I want to really talk
about but but briefly the goals of this
project are to take people who have some
apparently genetic disorder and sequence
just the gene containing reaches the
exome from her genome and compare their
their x own to other members that
relatively their parents to see if there
are mutations that might be responsible
for for their disease so I just want to
use an example of the scale of
sequencing so if you look at the human
and mouse genomes back in 2001 and in
2002 and the mouse was published the
number of reads that is individual
sequences generated by the sequencer for
those genomes is around 35 million the
reves are longer then we use Sanger
sequencing technologies they were about
650 base pairs on average and if you add
that up you get about 22.8
billion bases for those projects that to
get that to generate the genome and the
cost was around for the mounting of the
classes around 26 million dollars for
one of the trios a parent child and two
parents that we did two years ago here
at Hopkins we generated 235 million
reads they were shorter II this is
typical for Nexo they generate about
this many reads today the reason only
100 base pairs long so they were shorter
but the total number basis was very
close to the same about 23 they have
billion reads however the cost of those
three exomes a year and a half ago was
five thousand dollars and that cost is
already lower today so that just
illustrates that the cost of sequencing
is over five thousand times cheaper and
if you look at the throughput of our
sequencing machines the the speed-up is
even greater than that so that means
that we have enormous challenges to deal
with all of the state and that's created
an opportunities and challenges for
people like me to develop algorithms for
processing this data so so one of the
key concerns we have is that any
algorithm that you use to process data
sets of this size millions of reads for
hundreds of millions of reads or even
billions of reads your algorithms have
to be very fast be very careful about
how they how they use memory as well
otherwise your local well made
computational sources so one observation
sauce that's often made I made it myself
is that they the acceleration of
improvements in efficiency in c pacific
analogy have dramatically outpaced
improvements in computer speeds over the
past 15 years and that means that
although in 2001 when the human genome
was published we could keep up with the
data today we often can't the data is
coming out of our sequencers faster than
our computer system processing so one of
the first programs that that we
developed in my group was a program for
aligning reads to the genome so one of
the first things you want to do when you
sequence you generate a sequence is if
it's human is figure out where it came
from so we have a human genome only we
use that as we have a reference assembly
of the genome and although it's only as
an assembly of one particular person one
thing we can do for our analysis is we
can take short reads that are say a
hundred base pairs long or maybe a cup
basters long and align them to genome
the 3 billion base for genome I forgot
where they came from so back in 2009 my
former student and Langley who's now
assistant professor here at Hopkins
published developed and published a
method called bowtie which was and still
is one of the fastest short read
aligners of London's test and it uses a
very clever technique from computer
science developed in the data
compression field called the
burrows-wheeler transform to make it
efficient so this program is because
it's very fast and very efficient in its
use of memory it's become it quickly was
adopted by hundreds of labs and later
thousands of labs it's been downloaded
over 200,000 times in the papers
describing it the original paper that an
update that Ben and I published in 2012
had received thousands of citations
which is quite unusual for a scientific
paper so that just illustrates the
hunger there is for Memphis like this
now poet is a method that we use in
transcriptome analysis but I'm mostly
talking about the subsequent tests so so
today I'm gonna talk about focus on how
you analyze RNA seek later
so RNA seek is a little more complicated
and you can do more than just take the
reads online of the genome and figure
out where they came from and perhaps
figure out what the differences are
which you might do in a genetic study so
from our DC the pugmill is something
like this to sort of simplify things a
little extremely we we generate sequence
from RNA rather than from DNA so to do
that there's a lot of laboratory steps
that I won't go into but you can't
sequence RNA so we have to turn it into
DNA and that introduces some biases that
we have to worry about later on
computationally you turn it into DNA and
then then you do the same thing you do
with the DNA sequence you sequence it on
a high-throughput sequencer generating
reads that are typically a hundred base
pairs law under they often come in pairs
that you can keep track of so your
fragments of RNA might be say two or
three hundred base pairs long with your
sequence both ends capturing a hundred
base pairs from each end once you have
those reads off the sequencer that's
where the software really is to work and
has to then align them to the genome and
the alignment now is
I'll explain a little bit more in a few
minutes Who I am is going to have to do
more than simply the task of bow ties
could have to be more than just a lot of
attempted animus to have to account for
the structure of genes as they're laid
up in the genome but for an RDC
experiment I do much more than that we
actually want to reassemble the original
transcripts that is the genes that were
being transcribed that were being copied
from DNA to RNA and we want to figure
out from each of those transcripts we'd
like to know how much of it was present
in the original sample so want to
quantitate those transcripts and even
beyond that we would like to compare the
gene expression in one sample to the
gene expression another sample size want
to do what's called computing
differential expression so we would like
to software to go from these robberies
to this nice ideally a nice readout
showing us between our cases and our
controls which genes were over expressed
at which these went up and expressing
which went down our questioning by how
much so that's that's what the biologist
wants and somehow we have to get from
this raw read data to this very very
complicated readout of which genes were
expressed and what their levels were so
my lab was developed my students and
postdocs develop a suite of tools that
handle all the steps of this process I
mentioned bowtie already after doing a
mine with bowtie then you need to worry
about splice site which I'm going to
explain a little more detail next to
account for the presence of introns and
then you have to take those alignments
and assemble them together to
reconstruct the genes that were present
a sample and we developed a program
called cufflinks for that that was a
former student of mine named Colt rep
now there's now an assistant professor
humorous of Washington and cufflinks
does more than just assemble them it
also quantitate the transcripts and then
there's a fourth program called cuffdiff
now corruptive to also develop eye Kohl
trap now that can tell you that which
teams with different should express
between two sets of experiments so all
of these papers all these programs are
very popular all of them have been cited
in enormous number of times over 2,000
times of each station over 5,000 times
in the case of bowtie just to show you
not not only are people using them up
they're using them as part of scientific
papers up there and then
however we haven't rested on her laurels
those tools were mostly developed in
2009-2010 we've now developed some new
tools that I'll tell you about today bow
tied to as I already mentioned came out
a couple years ago very recently just in
the last couple of months we published a
new splice aligner called high SAP which
is a successor to top hat but uses a
totally different algorithm and we
published a transcriptome assembler
called string time it does assembly
implantation and my colleagues Jeff
Leake analyst he published another
another person I will not talk about
called bone which does the differential
expression step so let's let's look at
the splice alignment problem in a little
more detail now so before I talk about I
said let me explain about top hat -
which is a major improvement over the
original topic program and this was the
work of day one Kim whose former
president now a postdoc in my lab so
let's let me describe what the problem
is first so the challenge here is we
have these short reads they might only
be a hundred base pairs long sometimes
they're even shorter than that it's not
uncommon even today to get reads there
there's 75 base pairs long or
occasionally even 50 base pairs and we
get them in pairs and we want to align
them to the genome and figure out not
only where they came from but it's
possible that these reads that many of
these reads in fact span introns so this
is a little cartoon showing you here the
red boxes are exons and the skinnier
lines nikodem are the introns and in
yellow i'm showing you a reed that spans
an intron so we want to be able to
figure out that this realises the two
different exons and we want to do that
without knowing what the genes are so
the first attempts to do this when when
RTC was first invented only about six
years ago would just take the predicted
genes or the known genes and creepy the
transcripts that we know about by
concatenated together the exons and then
you can simply align the reads to to the
transcripts but when we're wanting to
reach to the genome if we don't know
really where the genes are then we have
to allow the recently split in a line of
two or sometimes more than two places if
they span more than two exons so how do
you do that so here's one idea and this
is the basis for the algorithm in the
original top hat program well let's just
take the reason and align them using
boat
and then II read that max matches end to
end within an exon will align very
nicely so we can just do that step first
that's very fast and from that we can
assemble together these little intervals
that are covered by by aligned reads and
those will be exons or in most cases
parts of exons you don't generally go
all the way to the edge the exon
although they might then from from those
locations we can find nearby splice
sites now human introns almost always
start with GT and end with Ag we can
allow for a couple of other alternative
splice sites in that but let's just
assume it's GT AG so generally we are
pretty close to the ends of exons when
we do is first in line with step so we
find the GT sites that are near the
beginnings of introns at the hg sites
they're getting ends of exons of introns
rather and and then computation we can
we can then concatenate what we think
are the exons defined by those sites and
ask do we have a read do we have any
reads that haven't a lot yet that would
align to this hypothesized by assumption
and if we do then we're done so that's
how the original type activity created
the the possible splice junctions based
on this initial round of alignment and
then look for initially on that reason
with the line across the splice and then
that works quite well there's there are
a number of problems that occur when one
of the some of them were the biggest
ones were addressed on top at - what is
the problem of pseudogenes which we
hadn't thought about at the very
beginning of that this sort of endeavor
so so what's the problem with
pseudogenes
so for splice alignment so here's an
another cartoon of a pseudo gene we have
a gene here with half a dozen exons
shown in green with the red parts the
untranslated part of exons and so
normally this gene which is in two
copies so at the top here where all this
gene we be transferring transcribe all
the introns would be removed so the
skinnier lines are the introns to be
removed and the exons concatenated
together in the port as you're producing
the RNA and the Selman adds the poly a
tail a string of A's to the end of it
and that could send later translated
rusa protein well once in a while at
lucien early speaking once in a while a
virus which is infected
which has a reverse transcriptase as
part of its genome will take that RNA
it'll reverse transcribe it back into
DNA and integrated into our genome now
this is generally speaking a rare event
in our lifetimes but over the course of
evolutionary time this happens pretty
often in fact is effective the human
genome many times there's there's
there's over 14,000 super genes known in
the newman genome and many of these
pseudo genes are are nearly identical to
to the gene that came from so why is
this a problem for alignment the problem
is if you look at this slide let's
consider that little Reed right in the
middle that little red rectangle that
spans two exons in the middle of this
gene so the true alignment the correct
alignment of that that reads should be
to those two exons however if the pseudo
gene version of this gene is fairly
recent as many of them are then that
that read more line end and very nicely
to the pseudo gene copy now generally
speaking almost always two genes are not
transcribed so that's not the correct
alignment that's not where this read
came from however if you're just doing
alignment you'll find a nice end and the
line that using that algorithm I just
described and you'll never even try to
look at a splice aligned with this gene
so we have to deal with that with that
kind of problem otherwise these
pseudogenes will essentially absorb all
the reads that come from the genes so in
topic 2 the solution was in in sort of
overview fashion was create transcripts
using the splice sites we discovered on
the initial round of alignment and then
take the reads that aligned that aligned
end-to-end initially and ask is there is
there an alignment in the transcripts
that we can the climate the spans one of
the introns we've discovered and if
there is we align that read and their
sign excited what we believe is that
what's usually the correct copy so
basically you rely on the fact that you
are usually going to find that correct
exons it's just that you won't have from
genes that have a pseudo gene copy you
just want to have enough reason to them
so you go after you found those those
transcripts you can go back and find
reseat aligned to the wrong place and
realign them and put them in the right
place so requires a second round so that
was in top a two and the result of that
and a number of other very clever
prove us that they want Kim came up with
worth of summarized at this table and we
have others like this and this is this
is showing you simulated data which we
use because with simulated we know
exactly where the beads came from and
you can see the accuracy shown along the
first column just there the overall
number of correctly map reads for top
hat along the top and then for other why
do you slice the line or show them on
the left and all of them do pretty well
in the 90% or above range and just look
at overall alignments but I'll draw your
attention to the two the number of reads
and aligned correctly across junctions
which is the third column numbers it
says correct Junction reads those are
the reason span and splice site and top
it still does very well with those but
not at 99% it's still 97 and a half
percent of those are aligned correctly
some and mostly on the program is drop
fairly substantially except for map
splice in this case and the really most
difficult regional I know the ones that
have very short anchor so we've defined
that here as a read where only 10 bases
are fewer Alliance to one of the exons
and the rest of the reader lines to
another X on those are really hard to
language you have a very short anchor
you only have a little tiny piece that
you have to then figure out where it
goes and it might be accurate thousands
of base pairs away so because of this
sort of to pass algorithm a top hat uses
it still gets 96 percent of those
correct words some of the other programs
except for map splice a look removes all
get 20 percent or fewer of those of
those types of alignments correct so
those are the really hard ones so so
that those improvements actually improve
the sensitivity of top hat and made it
made it even better than top that to be
better than top that one but we want to
be faster so because of all these
additional things is doing it was
slowing down data sets are have been
growing so how do we get more speed so
so day one Kim had the idea well when we
use bowtie for the first step this is so
fast why don't we try to use the
burrows-wheeler transform that data
structure on the algorithm still with it
which are very very fast why don't we
try to use that for everything or at
least as much as we can so that's the
idea the implementation though is
another thing so how do you do that
so that idea is implemented with a new
program called hiset which stands for
hard hierarchical indexing for splicing
of our transcripts
and there's picture k1 and the idea in
summary is shown here so you create a
global indexes before burrows-wheeler
transform HD then the conductor
something called the FF index for the
whole human genome and then you create a
huge number 48 thousand additional
indices each of them very small only
covering 64 kilobases and so they're all
very small indices in there and they
span the genome end to end and you make
them overlap by one KB so these indexes
Tyla genome with a small overlap anneal
in each one so let me tell you how we
then you and you can search them all the
same out when this burrows-wheeler
transform based algorithm which comes
from from bowtie so let's listen let me
describe how we do that so first of all
first let me point out that it might
seem like creating this huge number of
new
indices won't that take a huge amount of
memory won't they it be a problem for
forward running this on any kind of
reasonable computer well after a lot of
very clever optimizations day one I was
able to get this to fit into just 4.3
gigabytes for the human genome so 4.3
gigs is not too bad most you probably
have eight gigs on your on your desktop
or laptops today so you can run this on
a standard desktop machine without any
problems with it for the human genome so
so here's how the algorithm works and
I'll try to show you give you the sense
of why it's wanted so much faster - so
let's just look quickly at three
examples of three reads shown in red
here and let's talk about in my seventh
one so what I'm showing you here across
the top is a little a little piece of a
human chromosome with two exons
separated by an intron and in the middle
they're labeled eat one day - in the
middle I have those exons concatenated
and have three reads labeled one -
information that's red rectangles that
align to those two exons so the Reiser
and rad the exons are in yellow and the
atronics are in gray so for example one
was is an exon here that that that just
aligns with in a minute within an exon
so it's right here so that's easy we
just use the global bowtie index and
that aligns as as it did in top one to
top that - now let's look at a harder
example here we have a read with a with
a short anger so this read aligns
renumber to alliance in exon2 but it
overlaps it sort of extends into
excellent one by only a little bit so
what what hiset does is it first anchors
the read using the global index that's
the little blue arrow there sort of
indicating you go right to left and then
you know if you discover that ok this
read aligns to exon two and you anchor
it and then you extend that alignment
within exon two until you get to a
mismatch and that's shown in purple
there and then and that may leave us a
few bases at the end of the camp line so
what do we do we then pull out the local
index appears where we use those little
tiny indices we already know where we
are we now have a little tiny piece of
DNA might be eight or ten bases long
being problem that the top had another
splice lattice atoms they would have to
go back and look at the entire genome to
see where does that ten bases match and
it's going to match in a lot of places
however if we look in a local index
which is only sixty four thousand bases
long then that little ten base for a
piece in most cases will match in only
one place and will be the correct place
sometimes and will match it all maybe
our intron is longer than 64 Kb
in which case we'll just go and get the
next index to the left in this picture
sometimes I mentioned say two places but
rarely in more than one or two places so
our search is greatly constrained by the
fact that we have a very small window
that we're searching in and we used the
the initial search to anchor ourselves
and pull up this index so once we do
that we then search in this little local
index for that little piece and
generally find that very quickly and
then now we have our splice alignment
and then a third example is just a
slightly easier version of that where we
have the X on the reads spanning two
exons from the big accurate in both
exons but the operation works very much
like before you start by anchoring the
alignment in exon two we pull out the
local index and then we take the rest of
the read and we find that it matches in
exon 1 and instead of just a local
search we have to extend the match a
little bit but it works very similar to
example two so how does this work how
long does this work well here's here's a
picture on the simulated data again we
assume Lee did it because we know the
answer but we have lots of data lots
results on real data as well so here
this pie chart just shows you different
kinds of exons so too quickly how to
give you sense of what's going on this
is from a simulation which is fairly
realistic
so most reads do tend to align with an
exon so the big red part is the number
of the percentage of all the reads the
line inside of exons the next most
common type of read is shown in blue
those are the ones that align across two
exons with an anchor of more than 10
bases in each exon and then the green
the green and the sort of light green
wedges show you the the Rays aligned
across two exons where one of the
anchors is either small or really really
small that is less than 1 this is just
107 bases and then we have a few reads
so in a purple a small percentage of
purple little span three or more exons
that are even harder than one so how do
we do one of those so first in terms of
speed the whole point of Pi site is to
be fast by using this more sophisticated
indexing strategy so this chart shows
you speed measured in reads per second
and electricity certain versions of high
sat I should say the default version is
called high set H and this chart button
is just high setup you download the
program and so they're both about the
same speed they run at 140,000 about a
hundred forty thousand Reis per second
the only other program that really can
match that in speed is star which is a
little slower but it's still over a
hundred down threes per second and you
see it the far right there top hat is
not very fast so this is about
thirty-eight times faster than top hat
in this experiment and generally find
that it's going to be 30 or 40 times
faster on top and on most of the
datasets we've looked at so it's much
faster of course you care about accuracy
perhaps more than anything so here's
sensitivity the number of the percentage
of those reads that are aligned that you
see over on the far right top hat is up
with over 98% and high set also is over
98% and all the other partners are
somewhat lower and I should just be
clear the y-axis here goes with any
eight percent to a hundred percent so
all the programs are doing well they're
all at 92 percent or above but we just
showed this little part to emphasize the
differences so anyway I said did not
does not sacrifice any accuracy to get
that speed and then to zoom in a little
bit on one detail the hardest reads to
the line of the ones that have
short anchor that that's always the
problem are you happy these are the ones
with anchors are just one to seven bases
that is you haven't read we're 93 to 99
of the bases aligned in one exon and
only one to seven bases alive in the
next exon over so you have to look very
hard if you want to find out where that
goes many of the programs simply give up
on those or fail to align the reading at
all and you can see that here in this
accuracy and here the y axis goes from
zero to 100% so you see a lot of the
programs really have trouble with that
but high side is able to live over 80%
of these and the Olympic compete it is
taught back to which can get which can
do a little better on these very short
anchors at the cost of as you saw before
huge increase in compute time so that
was just published this paper it's just
published in March of this year and the
software is available at our website
so now we turn to the to the other main
problem I want to talk about today which
is the transcriptome assembly problem
which is to take these alignments and
put them together into complete
transcripts and from that I want to tell
you about a new program called string
tie that was developed by Ella Berta
who's an assistant professor here at
Hopkins in the center for competition
biology so there's there's two let me
just sort of back up a tiny bit and say
there's two major approaches for
transcriptome assembly but transcriptome
I mean the collection of all the RNA
transcripts that are present in a cell
or clutch themselves so that is all the
genes that are very active so the there
are there two major approaches but one
other to talk about today is shown here
on the left where you take your reads
from your rna-seq experiment you landed
in genome because alignments and splice
alignments with programs like like
bowtie and high set and then you
assemble those together and and you're
trying to not only assemble the
transcripts for each gene but you want
to reach need to know which isoparms of
that gene are present and you want to
quantitate those however you don't
happen to alignment there are programs
which I will talk about at all except to
mention them here that can do assembling
to know though the transcripts just
about looking at the reason as you do
with whole genome assembly computing how
they overlap one another and then taking
those the Cemil transcripts and you
might then align those lose you know if
you have
that's a much harder task and generally
doesn't work as well however it's very
very useful and in fact essential for
cases where you don't have a genome of
course I'm talking today about RNA seek
on the human genome where we have a very
good reference assembly but if you don't
have any reference assembly at all or
you have one which is very poor then you
might want to try to know about
transcriptome assembly but now let's go
I want to talk about this genome guided
or reference kind of transcript assembly
so the motivation for springtime so as I
said at the beginning cufflinks does
exactly this task and we've been using
that quite successfully for five years
our lab and many many hundreds of other
labs but the motivation was this example
shown here where we had this we're
looking with a collaborator Josh Mendel
at microRNAs and we're looking at this
particular micro RNA cluster that occurs
in an intron of this gene shown at the
top it's a little hard to see so if I
just draw this arrow here you see those
there's two isoforms of this gene one
which there's two exons alone one with
more smaller exons and and coupling just
unable to assemble this correctly we
tried many different settings in the
middle of the slide we have all the
different transcript assemblies that
cufflinks produced with different
different settings and it never produced
these two these two what we knew would
to be correct assembly so after
experimenting with different settings of
cufflinks we decided to try a new
algorithm entirely and that ended up
after about two years worth of
development it ended up being the string
time system that we've just recently
released and published so there's two
new ideas that string tie mostly the
focus on the second one but let me
mention both what is that we can
assemble the reach de novo first as it's
just said a minute ago you don't really
need to do that you can just align them
but if a recent assemble in an
unambiguous way then why not do it you
might be able to then essentially get
longer beads out of that and that should
help but the the core of the string
cation whether it was a different
different way of producing the
transcripts of assembly the transcripts
themselves and of computing the
quantities and in inherent in this
method is that you're doing assembly and
on occasion of transcripts
simultaneously or this or the same step
and that's not the way that any other
method works so let me kind of give you
a little bit more detail about that so
so it's sort of a semi can call this a
semi hybrid approach which is doing some
some assembly so you start with there
any seat breeds you assemble them into
something we call super ease which I'm
not going to really explain but it's a
conservative assembly step you're not
trying to assemble every transcript and
and just assembling things a little bit
and in fact in the current version of
swing die all we do is take a pair of
Reed's that come from the same original
fragment and we try to see if we can
assemble them into one longer Reed so
the frame was generally going to be two
or three hundred bases with read lengths
of 100 so we try to turn those pairs of
reason to single longer reducing this
assembly step but in principle we can go
much much far beyond that we're working
on that
as part of our future development so
once you've got those super reads you
align those super reads and the original
risk is you know not all of them get
converted and super easy lemon-lime into
the genome using bowtie and top hat or
bowtie and high stack and then you have
these alignments which are then the
input the main input to the string tie
algorithm and from now there's a line
that you then do assembly so string tie
just like cufflinks doesn't actually do
alignment it works with alignments as
input and principally you can use
alignments from other aligners as well
as input to certain time and what you'd
like to do is to assemble the
transcripts and produced for every locus
of the genome all the different isoforms
that locus that is the different
patterns of exons and introns and
quantities for each of those each of
those eye supports so here's an outline
how the algorithm works so given a locus
or a bundle of reads all aligned to the
same locus the assembly algorithm builds
a splice for F which I'll explain a
little bit more in a second and then it
iterates through these two major steps
so first in the splice graph that
corresponds to this gene so we're doing
this one gene at a time so in this flash
craft we find the heaviest path the path
of heaviest coverage has the most reason
to it so that what that represents is
the isoform of this gene that has the
highest level of expression so we're
going to assemble that one first and
then we build a different network which
I'll show you in a couple slides I've
called the flow Network and we use actin
s to make the abundance of this isuh
form and then we iterate never move all
those all those reeds that we've
assigned this Iceland remove them from
the from the graph recompute the spice
draft that we compute the flow Network
again and keep going until you've
explained all the days you just iterate
till as nothing else to explain or until
there's so little left that is not what
explains your blossom threshold so let
me say what slash craft is first next so
here's a splice graph of a gene with
number of different exons so the exons
are shown here in orange along the top
aligned to the genome and you can see
there's multiple this is intentionally
little complicated there's multiple
alternative splice variants in some
cases you have exons that are simply
skipped or introns that are included you
have exons that can that have more than
one beginning or end alternative splice
sites and beginning here into the exons
and so from of the alignments you can
figure out where these things are what
the splice crepin is if you look at the
graph well no that's a splice crap
representing these alignments and you
have an edge in this graph for for every
place where an X on either begins or
ends so if you look across the top you
see the numbers 1 through 8 those
represent the different intervals that
then represent different splicing
patterns so we created a node in the
graph for each of those intervals and
those intervals are bounded by where we
see splice sites and we draw and we draw
edges to represent possible paths
through the ground so generally speaking
the splice trap captures all the
possible alternative isoforms there's
all the possible combinations of exons
and introns that a given locus for these
graphs in that very begin complicated
and in general though the number of
possible paths through this class graph
is very large much larger than number of
actualized forms that are there so
somehow we'd like to go from the
spacecraft to a representation of what
the actual
isoforms or genes were that were they
were
the tissue that we were looking at in
the first place so one approaches the
cupcakes approach which I'm referring to
here as coupling since today almost
certainly the most widely used is SEM
transcriptome assembler and it has this
algorithm which is a very nice intuitive
appeal that it's parsimonious what it
does is it takes a splice graph produced
another splice description here and it
produces a set of isoforms that is
guaranteed to be minimal and cardinality
cardinality but as it's guaranteed to be
the minimal number of transcripts that
are required or necessary to explain the
pattern you see in the splice craft so
in other words of cufflinks as in this
example produces for face of forums we
can guarantee that you cannot explain
the data with fewer than four isoforms
now keep in mind that it doesn't mean
that for eyesores is the correct answer
there may be a different set of four
isoforms or there may be more than 4 X
forms that are the truth but it is the
most parsimonious answer and in this
case I'm showing you here this graph is
actually built from five isoparms shown
on the right from the true source of
scrap those five sizes isoparms but
cufflinks because it's very clever to
produce for eyes farms to explain the
data which with in this case not to be
correct so string tight tries a
different approach which is it looks at
the transcript level expression levels
simultaneously and if you look at the
expression levels for this data while
you were assembling it you might have
one would hope we would hope you would
produce the five iceland's because there
a better explanation when you consider
coverage so that's kind of the key
difference here looking by looking at
coverage for a number of reads that are
mapping to each each splice site you can
produce a different set of ice forms
that might be a better answer so how
does it do this well first we identify
formers
from our splice trap and we identify
that the heaviest path and that's that's
pretty straightforward we use a greedy
algorithm which it starts at a node the
graph which has the deepest coverage the
most recent signs to it and then we when
we walk to the right and walk to the
left
in that grab finding the adjacent nodes
that have the most reads that are
consistent with the path so far so we
pull out the weak off of caffeine spice
rack that's heaviest and that should
represent that spices bearing with a
greatest debt recovery
and then from that we built a flow
Network and this is a little confusing
and I'm not going to no time to go to a
great detail but here at the top I'm
showing you a gene with four exons so
that's at the top up there and in red
you see all the different reads that
align to that and then at the bottom I'm
showing you the the flow Network that
corresponds to this set of exons into
the set of reads and the photo to give
you just quickly the idea of how you
build it is you take each read or super
re-emits as some of them are and you
look at where it starts and where it
ends
and so you see across the top read a the
very top read there that one starts in
exon one and it ends in Exxon four so if
a splice correctly would then create an
edge which is shown down below that goes
from node 1 to node 4 and we've give it
a weight of water we add one to its
weight because we have one read that
goes from one to four and so we would
continue in that way to draw edges in
the flow Network and then we use a
maximum flow algorithm to compute the
maximum flow in this network when we're
done so maximum flow is an old an old
idea that goes back 50 years actually
optimization theory so there are good
polynomial time algorithms to find the
maximum flow once we have a network like
this and what you can think of a maximum
flow solution is doing is it's assigning
as many reasons possible to this
particular network so you can also think
of it like a system of pipes and a
network that has watering through it a
maximum flow calculation would figure
out what's the maximum amount of water
to conclude that network here we're
trying to get the maximum of the leaves
assigned to it now those reads will be
the ones that that can assign to this
isoform and that determined is quantity
so of course the proof of the pudding is
in the eating so how well does this how
well does this actually work so here's
some results on the string tie in
practice so the string tie is shown in
the upper right here string x link is
ours with the Souper reads which is
still not fully implemented so it does
only a little better but string tie
itself is the the green squares or
Diamonds here
and you can see that it's sensitivity
and so sensitivity is shown on the
y-axis and precision on the x-axis and
this is for 150 million 75 a spare pair
of reads these are simulated so we knew
the exact isoforms that they came from
and sensitivity means of all of the ice
alarms that were present and data how
many did you get exactly right and
precision is a measure of the of the ice
forms you predict accommodate those were
correct as you can always get better
sensitivity by simply spitting out more
isoparms but that would lower your
precision so there's always a trade-off
between them and as you can see compared
to cuff link scripture I see less of a
track which are for the leading
transcript of assemblers string tires is
clearly doing the best quite a bit
better beer about six or seven percent
better sensitivity anybody anyone else
in relative terms about twenty percent
better than cufflinks and cufflinks that
you can see also is clearly above the
other the other three programs here we
did actually say we did run a few other
programs on this data they generally
prefer work or worse than the ones that
I'm showing so we're not showing those
here here's some we have many more
results in harder than a recent paper
here's some results on real data looking
at only at known genes so this is a kind
of complicated slide I've circled the
string time results again string time
springtime with super reads our little
green boxes and you can see in each of
these eight plots string tire is always
farthest closest to the upper right
corner which is where you want to be in
each plot so these are at the gene level
and transcript levels showing two
different rows for different data sets
reported from tissues comparing string
tied to various other programs and the
way we measure accuracy here is a little
different because we don't know the
truth so what we did here was me we said
okay that's real data we don't know and
you principal can only know today what
genes were present but if there is a
prediction by any of these programs and
out the transcript by name is predicted
by any of these programs that perfectly
matches a known gene we're known as the
well-curated annotation from refseq and
ensembl so that has been about perfectly
matching I mean all the introns men
exactly about their left and the right
hands so if it matches if your
prediction matches a known gene
perfectly we'll say okay almost
certainly that gene was present that
tissue will consider that to be a
correct prediction
so using that is the way of measuring
and doing it the same for all these
programs we found that again string tie
is significantly that are usually 20% or
more better than all the other programs
and cuff links is almost always second
best by good marginal for the other
programs so so string tight is by using
this different algorithm takes into
account coverage we think that's that
that's the sort of secret about why is
able to be better than than cufflinks
I'm going to skip this slide so in
addition we get this sort of side
benefit which we were always thinking
about what weren't specifically
targeting with string tight and then
it's a lot faster than coupling so here
I have some timings on just two data
sets one of our simulated data sets and
one of our many real de says from from
human kidney I'm showing you the speed
in hours and you see string tight on the
Left let's just look at the simulate
data first those that data said it took
about three tenths of an hour couplings
took an hour and a half and the other
programs except for isoelastic took a
day or two days I said last day was also
quite fast it took only two point seven
hours but again slower than string time
I get bit on the real data it was only a
slightly larger data set but took a lot
longer to string tie about an hour and
fifteen minutes one two quarter hours to
couplings 15 hours traffic crash and
never finished scripture took several
days and iso last took about five hours
so string time generally compared to
cufflinks which is the state of the art
in terms of accuracy terribly it's
running anywhere from ten times faster
to sometimes on 20 or 30 times faster so
it's quite a bit faster and I think part
of that is because the core algorithm is
magical flora which we know we can solve
in polynomial time and the core of
cufflinks there's actually a TM
calculation that doesn't doesn't
necessarily halt in polynomial time so I
think that's how cufflinks get stuck
running much longer sometimes so there's
finally let me go back included by
looking at this motivation that we had
for
string taught originally so here is
slightly zoomed in
a bit more than I had before those are
those this is this gene containing these
microRNAs you can see here the two ice
forms that we could not get cufflinks to
produce this is the same exact dataset
that we that we've been struggling with
a couple of years ago we ran it through
a string tie and string tie produced all
of the experts you see along the bottom
in black the two that I've now pointed
to here in red precisely match those two
annotated transcript so we were very
pleased that after all that work we'll
went back to our original example that
we couldn't get right the companies
couldn't get right nor could any other
program that string tie can in fact give
this example right and you see there's a
bunch of other isoforms shown there if
you look at the actual data you'll see
that there are introns present in the
alignments that very clearly support all
those isoforms but they're not in the
annotation which which only shows two
genes here and here just sort of
parenthetically I want to mention that
this is a typical picture we see when
we're doing rna-seq analysis that if you
rely on the known annotation in most
cases most human genes only have one or
two isoforms shown and in most cases a
vast majority of human genes we know
well over ninety percent of UT's have
two or more isoforms president of some
tissues we don't know how many there are
so this is why today given the state of
our knowledge of the human transcriptome
I think it's always best to use a method
that allows you to discover new isoforms
because if you rely on annotations we
know you're going to miss most of the
ice forms that are present because
they're mostly not annotated today so I
just want to mention right for at least
the springtime I only reduced it
recently the preprint of the paper came
out in February we've got quite a lot of
attention here's and the rain at North
Carolina
tried it out on some sweeping data and
she tweeted about it saying she's trying
it on some soybean data that we're
crashing cuffdiff and if you look at the
time here I circled she started she
tweeted at 4:59 p.m. let's try this new
program out and then ten minutes later
5:00 to 9:00 p.m. it's done and it works
we were
happy to see that unsolicited praise for
springtime so you can hit string time at
our website which is shown here in fact
all of our software you go to CCPD ght
edu there's a software link there and
this program and and hi sat and many
others are all there they're all free
and open source and the papers I said
appeared online in February that only at
the print version just appeared about a
month ago so let me conclude by
acknowledging the people who did the
most work especially day one can lose
the primary lead developer for high set
and eloquent areas that lead developer
for a string time and I'll stop there
and take questions well thank you dr.
Salzburg for that informative
presentation before we before we start
the Q&A session I'd like to remind our
audience how to submit questions you can
submit questions by typing them into the
Q&A box which can be found in the lower
left corner of the presentation window
we'll try to answer as many questions as
we can our first question from Tammy
Morris or ash I'm sorry University of
Toledo her question is for fusion
transcripts how does one deal with
shearing which may lose information
these longer transcripts for looking at
translocations could be a problem or is
the addressed base on the number of
reads so that's a very that's a very
good question
fusion transcripts are a very
significant and distinct problem from
the problem that high site is addressing
and in fact we have another program
called top that fusion which is included
now at the top had to release it was
originally a separate program so with
fusion transcripts what the questioner
was asking about is you have a case
where in the original genome a sequence
there are two chromosomes or two widely
separate parts of the chromosome that
have been fused together and they have a
transcript that if you line it back to
the original genome it aligns the two
distinct genes and we call those fusion
genes or fusion transcripts so you can
discover those but that's not something
you can do in the process of
transforming currently today
a string tie can't handle that North can
any other transcriptome assembler
however if you just wanted to discover
fusion transcripts we have a program
called topic fusion which can do that
but it's it's a kind of a lot a separate
topic our next question is from Krishna
Patel from the Institute of violent
traumatic she has a two-part question
are one if there are locusts with very
high number of reads for examples cases
of employee
how would high high high sad I'm sorry
handle it too and if i sat takes more
than expected time for a single run what
should I anticipate so having a very
high number reach shouldn't be a problem
not sure what you mean by that but if
you had say a thousand reason lying to a
single site item we haven't had problems
with that kind of depth of coverage with
a thousand or a few thousand reads I'm
not sure where things would break down
how many thousands or hundreds of
thousands agrees you have to get before
it would simply be unable to handle it
at some point it obviously got to be
some limit but we haven't hit that so I
don't think that is a problem
you were asking like when when do you
give up what is taking a long time to
run again high set is much faster than
any other program out there except for
star which is also very fast we have
some timings in our paper that get you
through a typical times that maybe you
should expect for for typical data sets
so for data sets with with ten million
to 100 million reads it's going to take
a while but as I was showing you before
it can align it's going to depend on how
many processors you have so I would say
run and multi-threaded those so you can
use multiple cores generally get your
results back in less than an hour as
long as you whether you have a
multi-core computer with the
and you're not sharing with lots of
other people but I would say look at our
look at the hiset paper for some typical
timings and compare them to the size the
dataset that you that you're running to
get a good idea how long you expect away
our next question is from Rogan Rattray
of Providence Health and services can i
sat find local matches on a different
chromosome in the anchored sequence well
so that's really the same as the first
question you're asking about that would
be a essentially at fusion transcript so
the answer is no my sac can't do that
that's something that taught that fusion
can do we've already gotten this
question not only twice a day but from
others in the last month and we do plan
to to work on adding this feature to the
high sat in the future but it's not
there now here's another question from
kami Moorish University of Toledo
what about alternative transcripts would
these be missed if a given exon is
skipped or does the mismatch search for
the next exon so generally both high
side and spring tire the two of them
together are quite robust to finding
alternative Triscuits that's when we
spend most of our time and developing
algorithms at finding so when you say
alternative transcripts I see I assume
you just mean alternative splice
variants of the same gene so hiset
doesn't actually you can provide
annotation to it but it's not restricted
that annotation so all the alternative
transcripts that are present in a
particular sample that are expressing
particular sample should be should be
found by the program as long as there's
no even if there's just one read
aligning to it it'll still find that
alignment so it's not dependent on I'm a
known annotation here's
Christian from Krishna Patel constrictai
deduced nor isoforms if there are any
compared to cufflinks so can it deduce
more isoforms by the companies so in our
string type payable we actually did a
fairly detailed comparison which is of
course in the supplement of whether
string tie produces more isoforms or
whether produces ice forms of or exons
or then cufflinks or whether ice forms
there that are expressing higher levels
so I'm not different there's no real
simple summary of those results except
to say that that in general Louis I
which had more isoforms present were
were somewhat more accurately
reconstructed by string ties to pair the
cufflinks it's not the cufflinks got
them all wrong which shrink I did a
slightly slightly better job as the
number of different alternative isoforms
increased at a locus another question
from kami Moorish would this detect a
transcript that may not normally occur
in the genome but perhaps is generated
in a cancer genome meaning wooded detect
aberrant spliced products so as I said
already it's a fusion transcript the
answer is no we would not be able to
detect it but if it's a surprise product
that's that's a cause by read-through
transcription where to know to
transcripts may be or merge together we
can find that if it's if it's a an
aberrant gene product and that there's
just something that went wrong in the
cancer cell and bits and pieces of what
are normally introns are expressed as
exons absolutely we be able to find
those this is whatever the data whatever
the data shows is that's what the
program will produce
this question is from Kathy co2 I hope I
pronounce name correctly the agriculture
and agri-food Canada have you compared
string tied to Trinity so that's that's
a good question so as I explained at the
beginning of the string type part of the
talk Trent the there's two generally
very different approaches to
transcriptome Assembly Trinity is a de
novo transcriptome assembler that
doesn't use alignment among there's
there's three or four such programs out
there and I think Trinity is is one of
the best if not the best and we've used
it in our work too when we didn't have a
reference genome however if we have not
directly compared it but others have
compared to NOLA with transcriptome
assemblers including Trinity two
assemblers like cufflinks and generally
cufflinks will do much better than
Trinity and I think screams I will do
even better yet because we have the
refugee template to guide us and Trinity
doesn't so it's not really a fair
comparison so so in general we don't
really see the need to do that
comparison okay we have time for one
more question this is from kenan kabir
bjr i you have any de novo transcriptome
assembler or ghee analysis tools
developed by your lab so so no we've not
developed it to know how a transcriptome
assemble we've developed whole genome
assemblers in my lab but not to know
about respecto assemblers I can make a
shout out to to Brian Haas is one of the
key developers of the Trinity program
that was just mentioned Brian and I used
to work together and we have some papers
together but I can't take any credit for
Trinity he also asked about differential
expression software the the cuffdiff
package which is part of cufflinks is a
differential expression package
overcometh to is an entirely rewritten
or mostly rewritten package and that was
I was not part of that effort that was
led again by cold trap now at the same
time that string type came out
or my colleagues athlete and his student
Alisa receive published a paper called
ballgown and that is a differential
expression package in R and L up or taya
and I were both participants in that
although it's really led by Jeff and
Jeff Leake and Alissa for Z and we've
designed springtime to be compatible
with with bulk items so you can take the
alchemist ring tie and pass it to
cuffdiff or to ball gown or probably to
any of several other differential
expression packages okay well that's the
end of today's webcast thank you all for
attending as a reminder I would like to
let you all know that today's webcast
will be available for on-demand viewing
for six months from today's live
presentation you will receive an email
from lab roots
learning your when this webcast will be
available for replay we invite you to
forward that announcement to your
College who may have missed today's live
event thank you again for joining us
today see you next time goodbye